too easy jesus oh god oh good what good
to be back yes ah welcome to these
gentlemen dojo coming in hot real help
hon stanky dirty couple of muddy couple
of good show up a lot of positive
feedback yeah yeah watch out 17 reviews
on I to live 17 we're up to 17 God yeah
Steve Simone has 283 does he really I
don't know i'm joking ah to my left from
Detroit Michigan the city where the
water sucks yep lint Motown isn't even
there any governor should resign yeah
everybody's in jail the city up
crumbling yep Gary Kennan to my rights
from Pittsburgh Pennsylvania claiming to
be a comics t burn oh good we have an
incredible guest today yeah yeah man I
know I'm so happy to have him here a man
i know from New York City we started
kind of stamp at the same time we're
here together yeah I met him in New York
he's in LA you catch them all the time
on ESPN you know who he is you know the
voices they do know two voices you know
Denzel you know donkey you know Tracy
Morgan I'm not jay-z yeah it is Dean
Edwards out in the dojo so Joe also has
a show here on the network which I knew
about I told you about when you follow
my own protocol whether you said it
right the first time awesome you know
are you saying you say what is it what
is it our say no don't say his say the
name is oh I didn't Isaiah yeah I want
to put you on the scott spot make you
uncomfortable it's a conceit watch house
glasses fog up seeing the top his
glasses fog up yet so many time okay
let's get to it yeah Dean thank you so
much for joining us yeah thank you for
having me it'sit's coydt's the father
mocking protocol also on all things
how many drops every Monday and
subscribe comment and like for the month
protocol good to be good to be here with
we're in the gentleman the gentleman's
daughter oh yeah look here so you are
killing it now on ESPNU and Caliendo
yeah man I'm quite often yeah he said
you know what shoutout to frank caliendo
because he he you know in this business
so so rarely um do people look out for
other people and and I always that's why
I loved your show because you were like
guys the doors open get in here you know
and you pulled in other comics and other
friends you know and that's what
Caliendo did I did something for Super
Bowl 49 with him last year where they
needed someone to play Richard Sherman
since seattle was a wasn't in the Super
Bowl and so I characterized something I
did determine and the producers at ESPN
dug it so much that they hit me the
following summer and said hey Dean you
know what we'd love to if do you do any
other people that um we've seen you know
some of your stand-up and some of your
clips online who else do you do you know
based around the NFL around sports so I
said well I just throw people at me and
they sent me a video with probably 10 15
different personalities from from from
from from stephen a smith and his lip
and his forehead to uh to crit to chris
carter you know h/o effort um and beast
mode marshall it's just a bunch of
people uh coach tomlin you know right
right yeah coach uh cuz i if y'all could
see this right now you'd say wow he's
brilliant just on the high and yeah man
and tamil annoys looks like somebody
took a [ __ ] in his living room and he
just walked in here obviously he says
obviously a lot obviously um yeah we
just you know I this funny cuz mark
theobald a friend of a friend of ours
mark just called I have a picture of
Mark from this uh this LL Cool J thing
he did years ago so that's that's the
picture I have any that screen capture
look like he was doing an ad for
LSU sources and he just looks so happy
and harmless it be like if they have a
size 10 what are the chances and so on
so mark actually I was able to the same
thing I pulled markings so they said we
want to bring you in to do some sketches
uh this this NFL season and I said you
know what can i bring a writer and they
said you have someone in mind I said yes
so I was able to pull mark in us and
yeah we hope to keep it going you know
um they were happy with a bunch of
things we did we had a real nice on
Super Bowl Sunday Caliendo and I did
they split them into about four
different sketches like 90 seconds to 2
minutes sketches that ran during a NFL
countdown and you know they just hit me
last week saying hey we're looking
forward to next year you know so fast
they bring bring us back now you big
football fan no that's what's a lot
really yeah I don't watch i watch
football the same way uh you know like
your Nana watch football on thanksgiving
thursday you know me like it's only oh
does cheerleader cowboy you know and yea
doubtless cowboy chili that's how bad I
am at that was cheerleader Cowboys Oh
same way the TBS executives what
Sullivan in something that ok it's on
background little veggie over the guest
here I take it you didn't cast him he
was the audience warm up okay did the
war room okay okay she's behind camera
Talon yeah yeah yeah yeah I'd never
warmed up a drama right where that just
shut the [ __ ] up in the gene or yeah now
what is it like though because obviously
when you're the world of ESPN look it's
so obvious that you could you know the
big marquee names to go after them and
do impressions but again when you're
doing like a stephen a smith who is a
celebrity with himself right or michael
wilbon or any of these guys these ten
poles of the of the network is it tough
because you're going to be sharing a
desk with them at some point or you're
gonna pass him in the hall or no you
know what the flip side of it i was
really flattered cuz that day today not
you that's a good name for the writer
Caliendo told me later on he was like
he's like damn let me tell you something
there there Darryl they all want you to
do them they act like they don't but
they do because after we did like after
we decided we were going to do some my
first one I decided you know I want to
I'm gonna go in with a start with a bang
so I'm gonna do this sketch where it's
uh I want to do sort of like Eddie
Murphy at the the Klumps dinner table
where I'm just doing a bunch of
different characterize and so it was me
as Denzel me as Tracy Morgan me as uh
coach Tomlin and me is chris carter and
carter was interviewing Tracy and Denzel
and then Tomlin was live via motors and
so I and and for me it wasn't about the
front the first one I was like I I'm
doing a lot in a little bit of time so I
want it to be funny but I want people to
say wow that's crazy did that's all him
right and so after we did sort of a
rough and I what I did I had to send
them video of me doing a bunch of them
that was sort of like my audition to the
bigwigs at he has pin that would that
would say here's here's some money you
know right so we did one they sent it
they I didn't realize until the day I
got up to a Bristol Connecticut where
their campus is that they were showing
them so they showed so the day I went up
there on a tuesday and i think we were
shooting on what I went up on Monday we
shooting tuesday morning and so Monday
they're like they're like Oh Dean you
know what um we're gonna bring you in to
meet all the guys and so you're you're
you're meeting a you know coach Ditka
and your meeting uh Chris Carter and and
keshawn and the whole crew you know yeah
and so I walk in and they're all smiling
and then chris carter's like you got it
okay you got me you got me and your i'm
like wow you really do have large
eyebrows was enlarged eyebrows you have
grandma and and he pulled me to the side
man and this is what I appreciate it
Chris Carter pulls me the side CC says
uh he's like a man i just signed a
contract I'm gonna be here for a long
time you know Steven a is gonna be here
for a long time that means if just keep
doing us you won't be here you know and
and I appreciated that because I've done
impressions of other people that I'm not
gonna say any names on exactly who it
was that I did but they weren't as happy
that I was doing well i gotta say i
remember when i was in new york city
speaking of which the like I remember
you came onto the scene you do these
impressions before SNL and you had done
some show somewhere and we're all the
Boston comedy club which is not existing
was how long ago this was that was the
gym that was that was the jellies him
yet it was the house that Todd Lynn haha
hi Steve man let me tell you something
Maggie funny but you know you need to
stop talking about being Asian an
Irishman hot line right there every
night of my life every moment no no no
he was a topic great comic god bless him
he pissed a couple years ago shot from
the hip he didn't give a shitty right
[ __ ] he wasn't there to make friends
who's there to do his thing but he was
always just very honest that's why he
respected him I think like he was
overshadowed by Patrice at the time
right Reese was just so like literally
physically just so such a large person
but also like such a large personality
and Todd was I think very similar yeah
yeah they were I cut from the same cloth
like literally the same um but todd todd
that's Todd right there but I remember
so you had done this jay z impression
and everybody was going like batshit
crazy over it and then there was a show
you had done in New York and jay-z was
in the audience and got to see wow you
do it and it was the next day and people
were kind of like Oh Dean Kildonan jay-z
was there and then I think like within
like a year that's when I knew oh my god
he's killing it with the oldies
impressed and then all of a sudden you
got SNL so really that was the first
thing I remember back in the day in New
York here and like Oh Dean's got these
impressions down yeah well you know what
I had a is funny with the impressions
I'd stop doing them you know actually I
sense a stop I had stopped doing them as
heavily in the city because Lucien hold
grab all these people pass away Lucien
hold who used to run and book the comic
strip Lucien when I first audition to
get on there he had seen me uh when I
did def Comedy Jam in 95 so I was
thinking I'm in so I auditioned and he
Lucien was another straight from the hip
guy you know he said you know you your
impressions and your characterizations
are wonderful but you don't you don't
have any jokes and a lesser a performer
with a smaller ego or less confidence in
themselves might have let that affect
them but I'm always open to constructive
criticism aight so i said them i said
elaborate well you know when when Jerry
Seinfeld Jerry Seinfeld doesn't have
brilliant stage presence like you do but
he has brilliant jokes so when he says
you know why is it he called the best
man when it's not the man that's getting
married that's a brilliant job you know
and so run that I said you know what I
want I want the respect of comedians in
the comedy world I don't want to be just
I don't want to be rich little I don't
want to be he's in Russian asst so I had
I always had that like I would do the
impressions say on a weekend at Boston
or stand up New York the strip I doom to
kill if I have to close if I have to
follow tony woods and you and schapelle
showed up you know I'm like I we got a
win tonight so I'm shooting every
impression I have out but for the most
part i said you know i wanna i want to
start crafting jokes on a craft material
right so that i get the respect of you
and voss and Patrice and Todd I want I
wanted respect from my peers so that the
the probably the year leading up to SNL
in the city i was i was doing them on
the road I was you know I was like
running nakka at that point like yeah
some schools wow that boys boat up yeah
yeah and that's all you want as you know
I mean that's all you wanted you like
hide if I could get if i can get you
know 15 dates out of this national nak
appearance I'm good and I want a book
like 70 Wow and then and I burnt myself
out it became too much yeah and that's I
think that's always the trick in in what
we do is is knowing when to say no I
gotta stop right you know I remember Jay
be smooth was the king of the chitlin
circuit of the black comedy clubs and
one nighters all over the country and
every was like man JB just has if he
slows down it'll give to Hollywood a
chance to notice him in as soon as he
did yeah you know everything that's
happening for him started started to
really but to go back to what you were
saying a second ago like you know
sometimes when I when you think of these
Impressionists that are obviously
comedians it's like they'll go up and
they can just kill and kill and kill in
the impressions are spot on their
goddamn funny but right but you don't
know anything about that back former and
the one thing I boys respected about you
is that even when I think of you now as
a performer I see you sitting on that
stool oh you don't go up and you're not
like selling the impressions you
actually take a lot of time to spend to
pontificate and to do stand-up as you
write so I think when people think Dean
Edwards I think of you as a stand-up and
the impressions are secondary even
though the impressions are [ __ ]
awesome right so that's the way I thank
you I think most comics look at you that
way and I think that's a tough trap when
you because you could go either all in
on the impressions which is the easy
thing to do the harder thing is to do
what you did right right I've always
felt like it'd be the reward for working
harder than settling for the easy route
it it just it's worth more even is it's
intangible you know because respect you
know respect hearing you say that I
remember Patrice um on Jay Moore's
podcast I think was the his final time
his final interview and you know they
were talking about some know it might
have been an interview but um he was
like you know Dean Dean doesn't do what
what a lot of these cats out here doing
you know and I was like I take that as a
salute because I didn't why I worked
hard to carve out a niche I I know a lot
of comedians that are Impressionists
first writing kill and get two standing
ovations every night and destroy but
they're not you don't look at them like
oh did you see his special did you see
it you know I want people to like after
seeing me lately like DC Benny last week
I've been doing this sort of dark
material where I'm talking about suicide
and funerals and DC's like
Damon I saw a different you know I said
oh yeah would you he was like nah I
liked it like yeah just it surprised me
but it but I liked it and I was like you
know what that's what i like to do cuz
again it keeps people guessing and then
uh you're unpredictable where they don't
know like you at the end of my shows
when I'm on the road um even last week
someone someone yells out while I'm on
stage uh I think at the factory on
Thursday night I done had done the
suicide material I've done this dark
material and then as I was getting ready
to get off stage I hear do guns out you
know and I've learned I've come to to
grips with being comfortable with that
because I know it's coming from a place
of respect and admiration right and so
they're yelling that out like a man this
my girls birthday please do i know you
do this one thing please do yeah you
know and send yet years ago I that
annoyed me until I said you know what
that means they dig is it's like it's
like going to see prints and then please
do purple rain you know yeah it's your
greatest hits you know your macaroni and
cheese is one of your greatest bits area
I don't wanna oh you don't have any no
no people do shout out during Steve show
but they're always yelling wrap it up
shut the [ __ ] up I'd tell the club all
right he's a special guest okay yo but
it was like demon saying but like with
chappal when he would come into the club
and everybody would want to see Robert
James single Robert in so it's this
really nice right of sense of hey that
people really know you well what was the
first what was your first impression
where you think I was axin Michael oh
well when I was a kid when I was a kid
yeah tables Bugs Bunny you know yeah I
think just because as a child I you know
people always ask well how did you how
do you know it's funny how people come
up like yeah man I want to do
impressions hey how do you do that I'm
like it's not how it works you know it's
just it was just a natural gift that I
had from mimicry and and so as a kid
watching us watching you know Bugs Bunny
and
you know mimicking dog dog I said I say
you know uh parlez leg hundred seventy
same you know all of them and and if you
listen as I've gotten older you listen I
those are all the same person you can
annul like yeah if you listen you're
like that's Mel blanks on you can hear a
certain undertone to ya each vocal vocal
characterization and so uh yeah you know
I would do that and then bring it to
school and my friends like oh yeah and
there was something or you know exciting
about being a kid and having everyone's
attention sheriff doing doing these uh
these weird voices so you have a knack
for the voices and then obviously the
one thing we have to ask I think cuz
everybody loves the show and knows it
obviously where were you when you got
the call that you got SNL I was uh I got
the out tell the story quickly as part
of our inspire sick of hearing it cuz
I've said it Kota but I i I've always
yes inated like where you were i was
actually well here's was funny i booked
MADtv first oh wow oh and another little
tidbit I said no to SNL at one point
before I got it quick so ago really uh
I'd addition for a sketch show the year
before remember UPN the head the head we
had like a sketch show they saw me in
New York flew me out here to LA i stunk
I bomb went back to New York licked my
wounds I was like I'm never one
experiencing you and gary said Gary
stayed here back to me I should elect so
I own so go back to New York I said you
know I gotta figure this this outside I
found like a second city satellite
improv class took that for it was right
above the comedy cellar right it was
like oh yeah show room above the comedy
so took those classes next time MADtv
had auditions coming up in like may june
of 2001 so I said yeah I and I happen to
see Jimmy Fallon's audition tape and
with most sketch shows they do three
characters three impressions so I said
you know what my strength is my
impressions as long as I keep it within
three minutes i'm going to do as many
impressions as I can so I i wrote a
sketch where I said this is my
impression of
of Chris Rock and Chris Tucker hosting a
black awards show that jay-z & erykah
badu do a duet and then Denzel
Washington and Sam Jackson present a
lifetime achievement award to James or
John alright so i did i said that i
recorded it rehearsed it a bunch of
times and then when it was time for the
man TV audition I'll never forget it was
myself I think it was dining rawlins
maybe Owen Smith was there yeah I go in
first supposed to be in there 3-4
minutes I was in the 10 minutes and by
the end of it nicole garcia shallots and
nicole garcia she casting it and she
says to me who else do you do and so she
wow so she's like i said i don't know
throw she's like Steve Harvey I like
whatever y'all need me to do I want you
know and I was just and never did a
Steve Harvey but I knew enough of his
new ones that I cried do something with
it so uh they gave me a call back for
the next day I leave and Darnell's oh yo
young'n I don't know what you did in
there but everybody hates you out here
hahaha actors are like well how are we
supposed to follow that oh yeah so I
leave I'm walking up to Broadway and
70-something Evan and Steinberg my
manager at the time cause he's like yeah
I don't know what you did but they just
called and said they want you for
producers tomorrow other okay so I'm
excited right so that night we had a
showcase time ever had a showcase at
stand-up New York um I'm geek because I
had a great audition so I kill cuz I'm
sort of in the zone I go back for the
call back where they had me read a
couple of scenes that goes well two
weeks later I'm shooting a commercial
for KFC black man doing chicken water
her taxes so oh I remember wearing west
nyack shooting right across the Tappan
Zee Bridge shooting it my agent calls
he's like hey handsome I've good news
and better news only was a good news he
says good news is mad tv they want to
just they don't even want a screen test
you they want to offer you six episodes
and it'll roll to 13 if they like you
I'm like I cool my lady's pregnant at
the time something up yeah cool I said
well was it better news he's like well
that night that you had to showcase
people from SNL we're in the audience so
I was like oh okay so what's that he's
like now I get it and you said oh he's
like yeah I get to be an agent you know
and I was also going to Montreal that
that year so he took that tape sends it
out to every Network um the network's
all interested I remember um and man he
was at Fox and she really was one of me
and everyone was saying don't let him
sign that that thing for SNL the only
he's gonna get lost in the shuffle at
SNL but SNL has the history you know
yeah regardless of getting a you know
half million dollar deal with with a
network or mad tv was all for me SNL is
sort of the Gold's that the platinum
standard yeah you know so uh so fast
forward and we're trying to figure out
what we're going to do we we we we were
able to hold off MADtv for a couple of
weeks yeah finally we find out SNL in
order to screen test for SNL they get
first refusal so if I if I say yes I'm
gonna screen test that means i gotta say
no to MADtv and I didn't I was like well
they've been so nice you know it was so
nice and so my lawyer said well
sometimes because SNL can make you wait
three months and I was like well I'm
going to my trio we don't want to blow
it so he said sometimes you gotta have
balls and say no to get what you want so
I tell my agent I tell him no and I'm
like I good that's a that's a weight off
my shoulders an hour later we meet at
CBS on fairfax and he's like we got him
to budge they'll give us an answer in a
week damn so now we definitely have to
say no though so now we have to say no
to man TV yeah so bad uh Kevin Hart is
auditioning he calls me Kevin aight ty
he's like yo Dee man yo I mom I just got
got word I'm audition for us SNL I am
I'm not nobody knows I'm auditioning
right cuz i don't want comics like yo so
what's going on so I don't tell the only
person that knows eventually is Ian
Edwards because I needed to get it off
my chest right in and my and my future
wife knew what was going everybody else
nothing so I tell keV he's like yo can
you help me prepare so I'm like hey you
know well he's cuz cuz he's still my
friend of course you know and i'm like
i'ma look out for him and and who and
I'm always like what's meant to happen
is gonna happen you know so I helped him
and then eventually i told i say yum
I'm auditioning too I'm screen testing
to his eye I oh well let's listen let's
knock it out you know cuz we both were
like we're both audition for SNL we're
both going to Montreal we're winning you
know yeah we both have some sort of heat
so I go screen test on Thursday July 12
I'm the last one of the day they maybe
they made me wait I always feel like
that was Lauren's way of saying if you
you what made us wait now we're going to
be hahaha now now we're going to see
what kind of impressions you do under
pressure um but I remember Eddie Murphy
always said a you know when I auditioned
I just I said hey i'ma have fun so
that's going through the doors when they
called me I got there like noon I go
like 530 they call me I you see home
base where everyone's delivering their
their monologues I get on stage there's
a camera on me but there's a monitor on
top so I see myself oh yeah and it looks
like I'm delivering a monologue so I'm
trying to be cool but then I'm like hehe
I'm this big grand Laura's like Dean
thank you for coming on my guilt thanks
for having me and uh and people always
said you know don't expect less that the
sketch that I had read that joint killed
I heard last in the darkness wow I left
there saying you know what I think it's
a good look monday comes that was
thursday the Monday comes my agent calls
he says all right so Lauren wants to
meet you on Wednesday and the first
thing I think is but I'm going to
montreal i got i gotta put cuz we you
know as comics we've worked hard that's
the data to the fest yeah i've wanted to
get to this for so long don't tell me I
can't go right so what you go to the
festival so you can get what you have
boom yeah so that's what happens so my
agent says uh he's like he's like no we
already let them know and they said
Lauren's gonna just get you a ticket to
fly up later after your me so once I
heard that I was like oh I think I got
it you know he just now he wants to size
me up and see what I can do about my
afro so I so I get my time so yeah so I
get my hair cornrowed because i know
they wear a lot of wigs and he even he's
like know about your hair I said I said
that's why I came with it like you know
because Timmy when Tim Meadows started
his hair was very short and then by the
end he had a lie he had you know full
locks so that the wigs always look crazy
for
then Lauren never hires you he doesn't
say you're hired he said to me at the
end after sitting with him for a half
hour he says well we'll see you here and
so when I walked out of the office um
the producers marci klein a couple
others they're like so so I was like
yeah nice guy and they're like no but
somebody I said um what did did did he
hire me should I guess I was like oh cuz
you still don't know cuz she didn't he
didn't say you're hired yes it will see
you here you know and then the a car is
waiting downstairs to bring me to the
airport to fly to mantra dude oh go to
Montreal the festival no I mean you just
got SNL how I mean that's the greatest
it was it was awesome and because there
was no pressure and I'll never forget we
got up there might they told me I
couldn't tell I couldn't say anything
otherwise what was the point so we had
to we had to let it seem like i got it
at montreal so yeah i get there like
mark hirschfeld from mbc casting he's
like congratulations i'm like i don't
know what you're talking cuz i don't
know if he's if it's right agent so I'm
like I don't know nothing yeah and I'm
tired cuz it's been a long day care of
course Kevin Hart has always been a
hustler right you gotta respect this
hustle so keV cause knees you're Dean
what's up way we're at I said man I'm
tired I'm resting he's like yo he came
up here come on man you gotta come down
to the Delta you got a politic man I'm
like hi so I got it so I go in I gotta
play this whole role and then after my
second showcase set on Thursday night
that was Wednesday Thursday night I was
able to then go and tell kev i was like
i got it and yeah man it was it was it
was just it was awesome because then
everyone Richie tankian is up there and
he's like it didn't come in so you gotta
somehow let me tell you about when when
Eddie got answered you know was just it
was great having having that type of
attention man and then uh and then 911
happened the day I was supposed to start
oh wow yeah my first day of work was
supposed to be uh my first the first
official day for all cast and writers to
assemble was Tuesday September 11 2001
and he got preempted and it was because
we had met we as Americans had never
experienced
that that sort of trauma um I actually
remember cinema I remember calling Kenny
a mom who's one of lauren's lieutenants
I was like Stu um do we still am I still
hired cuz I was like is is is does life
go is it remember that kid is this life
yeah let's go cuz I was like are we
still gonna make I have a wifey yeah
it's just it was weird cuz I I watched
the towers from my my window in Park
Slope I watched the them phone on fire
and I watched them colors from my
bedroom window you know so is it was a
tooth it was a crazy it was a crazy
summer to say the least yeah and then
when did you guys go to work well and
then we started the following week Oh
father that that week I don't know if
you remember Steve but did do you
remember going to like Boston comedy
club like the week of 911 and and not
even to get on stage with just sort of
to like just uh you know commiserate
with each other fellowship with us I yo
what hey what the hell you know yeah I
remember clubs were closed for
definitely four or five days and then I
think the seller or Gotham was the first
open and then the other clubs fell in
line and then when you as a comic of
those four or five days i remember in
New York going I gotta get a real job
nobody's gonna comic right now and Rob
this is done this dream is gone right
right now it sucks I it's over right and
then you go there and you realize people
just spent four or five days glued to
their television but they're depressed
they need an outlet watching the loop
watching them exactly of them
continuously for that that's to me
that's what uh that's one thing that
bugs me about the meeting cuz I remember
saying to myself I was I actually forced
myself I said turn this off because i'm
watching people die I'm yeah there are
people in there that are not getting a
there was a comic dog face he was in one
of the towers and you're watching that
happen I was like this is not good
psychologically yeah to constantly see
that's why I was so bugged with the
whole like like Eric garner getting
strangled by the by the police officers
in Staten Island and you know people
with this whole black lives matter of
movement as a viewer as a parent I'm
like yo
this is we shouldn't say you're showing
someone get killed dying yet on a loop
well I and you're hearing him say I
can't breathe I can't breathe why are
you showing that why are we seeing that
why is it okay to see a black male get
killed on a constant news loop you know
yeah and so that's that's that's
something that that uh I i hope the
media is is is a is getting away from
doing you know there's still there still
are the killings but i haven't seen it
said because now it's like it's like
every few weeks or like so it has anyone
got shine a big shot anyone slow news
day yeah you know and and but i just
hope that they start minimizing what
they show you know cuz it yes
desensitizes Oh completely I mean
especially the last two summers and you
just there's that one footage even as
you're talking now I just element in son
oh oh we're talking I'm more tragic you
know yeah remind me of Ricky Gervais
Stephen Merchant worse said that was
just on a loop of that bar you just kept
seeing that ball the worst you are the
worse by the way later this week Dean
steve is gonna be auditioning for that
UPN sketch show it's a shut the facade
on the up my god I do an impression a
lot of people don't know this i do an
impression i'm irish in korean I'm out
of work if anybody needs an extra worker
at subway i'm steve byrne okay that's my
impression Thank You Dean honey think
right on the macaronis the mackerel I
gotta tell you when he was telling that
story yeah about getting started at lab
in the whole day I literally had to
chill up my spine just hearing necks I'd
not heard that story that's varying
credits toward yeah Dean we cannot thank
you enough for coming in and listen you
can find Dean on his own podcast on all
things comedy thanks come before the
mother mother protocol yeah follow me on
social media at I am Dean Edwards and
watch them on ESPN and countless other
famous keep killing at my friend thank
you so much for joining Avenue thanks
Gary anything to I saved Nelly no yeah